[Music]
i love
english so i'm a student in the british
council i love
learning with british council because
the teachers are friendly
i love learning with the british council
because i
enjoy spending time with the friends i
make it helps us in developing
self-confidence with the support of our
expert teachers
it helps me develop my english skills
presentation skills
and accent i get to express myself
freely
share my experiences and think out of
the box
the teachers teach us the fundamentals
of english and focus on our speaking
skills
the lessons are enjoyable and somehow i
feel like i'm in english
and all the activities are fun for all
ages
it can help us in the future and that
really makes me happy
with my english skills i want to visit
london
and meet the queen i want to study
engineer in the uk
and the english is really important for
me to make my dreams come true
i want to reduce pollution poaching and
save humanity
i want to be an airplane pilot with my
english skills
to write stories and communicate with
others so
i can talk english to my cousins
and my family i want to go a uk
i want to go to observatories
i want to have a job in nasa and also
travel
and connect with people of diverse
cultures
and ascervante said sky is the limit
english
is the language that bonds every country
together there is a no
better place to learn english than the
british
council and not to forget you get to
make some really good friends for life
british council helps me to improve my
english
skills and i'm getting closer to my
[Music]
dream